طيب الرئيس الامريكي السابق فاز على
الممثله ستورمي دانييلز باحدى الجولات
القضائيه واستخدم اعتقاله بقضيه شراء
الصمت كدعايه ناجحه لحملته على الانتخابيه
حتى اللحظه فما الجديد في التحقيقات
تحقيقان جنائيا اخران يشاركان على
الانتهاء الاتهامات فيها كبيره ليست فقط
ضد ترامب ولكن ربما عشرات او اكثر من
حلفائه وفقا صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اول
التحقيقين يركز على جهود المزعومه قام به
ترامب لقلبي نتائج انتخابات 2020 في ولايه
جورجيا فيما الثاني يتعلق بهجوم السادس من
يناير على مبنى الكابيتول
مايكل كوهين المحامي الشخصي السابق لترامب
اكد ان توجيه الاتهام الى الرئيس السابق
يخدم المساءله والعداله لكنه فظيع بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده على حد التعبيره
وصف كوهين يوم مسائله ترامب بالحزيم مضيفا
انه سيعطي نظره ليست بجيده للحلفاء
والاعداء معا باعتبار انه اول رئيس في
التاريخ الولايات المتحده يتم اتهامه
يذكر انكو هنا اعترف امام هيئه محلفين
كبرى بانه مذنب في اتهامات تمويل الحمله
الانتخابيه بمساعدته في ترتيبات السداس
السداد عفوا
تبادل الانتقادات في الاسابيع الاخيره لا
سيما ان الاخير وصف توجيه الاتهام الى
ترامب بالضروريه لانه يحتاج الى ان يحاسب
على افعاله القذره وفقا وصفه اذا كانت هذه
هي الطريقه التي تظهر او تظهر بها الحقائق
على حد قوله
المزيد انسانيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات